цей звук дедалі частіше тероризує
столицю та інші міста України
наближається мопед так прозвали іранські
дрони і шляхет 136 за характерних гуркіт
в повітрі на скільки вони небезпечні та
як їм протидіяти
шахит 136 під маркуванням герань-два
ірана заперечує продаж своїх Дронів в
Росії але за даними українською розвідки
Москва замовила у тигранах приблизно
2400 безпілотників дрони Камікадзе шахед
136 маркують як герань-два максимальна
дальність польоту до двох тисяч
кілометрів ефективна до тисячі
крейсерська швидкість близько 180
кілометрів на годину боєголовка містить
до 40-50 кілограмів вибухівки завдяки не
великому розміру та низькій висоті
польоту безпілотники складно виявити
радарами систем протиповітряної оборони
як правило зараз Росія їх використовує
Над Дніпром вони летять Практично всі
над річкою так по русло річки відповідно
низька летить низько над річкою це ще
одна додаткова перешкода коли важко його
коли летять ракети все ж таки простіше в
нас засоби виявлені є і поставлені в
звичайно додатково тому ми це бачимо
більше іранські дрони доволі дешеві
зокрема через це їх і стала активно
використовувати росіян адже ракети на
складах дедалі менше а на виробництво
нових піде чимало часу до того ж
багатьох компонентів бракує через
західні санкції за оцінками експертів
один шляхет 136 коштує приблизно 20
тисяч євро тоді як ракета калібр 6 млн а
деякі види інших крилатих ракет ще
більше
очевидно що у Росії закінчуються
високоточні керовані боєприпаси у них
звісно ще доволі багато інших ракет та
артилерійський снарядів цієї старої
зброї але в них недостатня кількість
високоточних ракет керованих ракет тому
за рахунок Дронів вони хочуть досягти
своїх цілей
як протидіяти дронам камікадзе
розмір і низька висота польоту що робить
ці дрони важко помітними для ППО це
одночасно і перевага і недолік їх видно
неозброєним оком добре чути Через гучний
звук і висоти польоту достатньо щоб
збивати стрілецьку зброю на цьому відео
патрульної служби поліцейський у Києві
збили один з Дронів зі звичайного
автомата Калашникова
[музика]
за словами експертів найефективніший
спосіб знищення Дронів камікадзем
загороджувальний вогонь коли стріляють у
фіксовану точку на шляху безпілотника і
він сам залітає у хмару куль при цьому
МВС закликає власників зброї самостійно
не намагатися збивати дрони особливо
поміж багатоповерхівок адже це може
призвести до жертв серед цивільних
також можна застосовувати станції
глушіння безпілотників які допомагають
змінити точку призначення дрона та
відвести його від житлових об'єктів
генсек НАТО йенс Столтенберг запевнив що
Альянс на дасть з Києва відповідні
системи для боротьби з дронами
наслідки для війни РФ проти України
ці дрони хоч і є дешевим замінником
дорогих крилатих ракет все одно завдають
великою шкоди вбиваючи мирне населення
та руйнуючи критичну інфраструктуру втім
на думку аналітиків та військових
експертів іранські дрони не матимуть
суттєвого впливу на хід війни
ця зброя це зброя терору це зброя
залякування яка покликана посіяти паніку
в першу чергу серед нас серед українців
не посіє так дуже боляче так гинуть
мирні мешканці так ворог лютує і
кажеться але переламати хід цієї війни
ці дрони Камікадзе не зможуть Я
впевнений на цьому 100%. після так
іренских Дронів на Київ 17 жовтня під
стінами посольства Ірану в Україні
активісти провели акцію протесту
звинувативши Іран у підтримці тероризму
та вбивстві українців протестувальники
розкидали каміння з будинку в якій
влучив іранський безпілотник і вимагали
припинити постачання Росії Дронів
Камікадзе українська МЗС назвали Іран
співучасником російської агресії воєнних
злочинів та терактів Росії проти України
а президент Зеленський закликав західних
партнерів надати більше систем ППО
коли ми кажемо про потребу України у
засобах протиповітряної протиракетної
оборони Ми кажемо про реальне життя які
забирають терорист нам вдається збивати
частину ракети Дронів лише за 12 годин з
9 вечора неділі вдалося знищити 37
іранських шахедів і кілька крилатих
ракет але щоб гарантовано захистити наше
небо і звести до нуля можливості
російських терористів потрібно значно
більше сучасних систем ппу і більше
забезпечення ракетами для таких систем
Україна також закликає накласти санкції
на Іран за допомогою в агресії Росії
проти України у США та ЄС вже
обговорюють відповідні кроки за словами
речниці Білого дому є всебічні докази
застосування Росією іранської зброї
проти цивільних цілей в Україні